you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui je
vais exécuter vos ordres en vidéo c'est
la troisième fois qu'on fait ça et c'est
la troisième fois que ça va mal se
passer pour moi le mec qui roule pour
confiance est partie danse et chante
comme dans chandelier de sya alors c'est
vrai que le clip un peu spécial la danse
l'est encore plus mais n'empêche la
petite fille qui lance elle assure grave
et je vais essayer de gérer tout autant
qu'elle
bon ça c'est extrêmement mal passé
malheureusement j'ai le pied de la table
à repasser comme une marque au fer rouge
j'avais que l'état leur passé et est
maléfique dessine avec les yeux fermés
ce sera pas plus moche que la girafe
non mais vous d'elle avec les gars les
écoutes ça va j'ai du feutre de qualité
avec toujours une petite feuille blanche
à quatre on va tester certaines jamais
essayé de faire des saints aux yeux
fermés on va voir c'est parti hilton
voir ce que ça a donné
je ne comprends plus rien quelle est
cette sorcellerie les yeux fermés oui du
démon te faire ta position de victoires
jambes en l'air à ton char alors poteau
qui ne connaissent pas c'est vrai que
c'est dans une ville aux frais gaming
j'ai fait cette position après avoir
gagné un truc ça sa position des
victoires à chaque fois j'ai besoin que
tu es un mec pas les pieds quoi j'ai
déjà fait cette blague mais j'adore la
sphère sous des couches avons la
pression de la victoire de jumbo il a
gagné voilà il arrive n'est rien et ça
ce succès un gagnant ça se voit
d'ailleurs à sa tête écrasée mais il a
gagné beaucoup de beaucoup de combats
contre des murs essentiellement imitent
les nouvelles photos de kim kardashian
tue c'est celle où elle a un verre de
champagne sur les pas de dire nicki
minaj était tellement réussis alors
c'est vrai qu'en langage nicki minaj
vient je me débrouille plutôt pas mal
voilà après le langage kim kardashian
l'un est un peu plus compliquer photo ap
les les gens par quelqu'un avec de la
cire comme un homme sans pleurer alors
chaque mike a eu cette fameuse blague de
la bande de cire collé sur la jambe un
mois y compris est écouté aujourd'hui
c'est du très très lourd parce que c'est
pas des bandes de cire c'est de la cire
un pur experte en fait c'est dans une
machine comme ça la syrie est en train
de fondre et je devoir l'étaler sur ma
jambe à l'aide d'un bâton comme ça hors
jeu létale ensuite je colle cette bande
de cire dessus et l'aja rage ok c'est
parti alors je sors mon mollet de foetus
informe est un petit peu sur le poignet
pour tester la chaleur du liquide ni
calza face mickaël vraiment voilà et là
les amis d'att attend que ça refroidisse
et que ça accroche bien tous tes poils
extrêmement peur et il faudrait je suis
pas faire ça un truc
les filles et moi s'il vous plaît c'est
vous les pros comment ça vous ne vous
épiler pas elle vaut près 1 2 3 ha ha
j'ai sous-estimé la puissance du truc
encore un fruit du démon ça marche et
regardait zoom caméraman y en a pas ça a
marché mais un tout petit polo ya plus
fruit du démon le dire ce qu'il en reste
encore un peu là je suis pas trop
comment je vais faire je vous avoue le
silence le courage
oui c'est moi je m'épile est donc en
fait ça fait tellement qu est ce que je
fais regarder une petite zone de non
poil ici voilà poil interdit match sur
les mains sur toute la longueur de ta
chambre
bonne chance eh bien tu vas être très
surpris 1 ça t'apprendra de mépriser
jackson sommes là à la gt3 d'angine ok
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est steve pas
mon gars là c'est un petit peu l'ostal
j'avoue et il faudrait quand même que je
puisse passer au moulin s'est passé je
suis dans ma jambe 480 sur ta chaise
tout en faisant le poireau ok je relève
le défi c'est parti dont 480 je dois
commencer de dos pour finir de face
voilà attention il vous près 180 360
tada c'était 1 480 poireau c'est drôle
non un tuto mode avec ce quiz est écoute
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien ça fait
un an qu'on l'a pas vu je sais pas où
aller hélas elle pourrait faire un petit
tour ce serait beau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette vidéo
la dernière fois j'avais appris comment
bien fait un petit fond d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui je vous apprends comment
bien ça me dégoûte un tuto mort
aujourd'hui
vous aussi vous allez avoir besoin d'un
sac poubelle avec lui sinon vous allez
délicatement couper le bel 5 ha parce
que sinon il n'y a pas trop donc on peut
balancer ou alors on s'étouffe comme une
merveilleuse
après ceci avec la peur de vous couper
deux petits arcs de cercles de part et
d'autre du sac poubelle afin dé
domitienne bon quand vous voulez ensuite
votre billet prêt ou presque
elle était bien sa petite blague un
humour squeeze êtes vous me déshabiller
ah bon on ne va pas vous voyez là ça
quand même où l'amérique une fois que
vous serez donc donné ça c'est pas
vraiment votre attention petite astuce
c'est un sac poubelle vous avez juste
ici un petit bouton très utile puisque
c'est connu
mais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est déjà
la fin du à vos heures de pilotes 3g
celle-ci vous a plu c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo comme
d'habitude [ __ ] pourquoi j'ai dit oh
[ __ ] la fin de cette phrase savait pas
lieu d'être et vous faites bien de le
relever
même si c'est moi qui le rôle m j'arrive
plus à suivre ce qui se passe n'oubliez
pas de monsieur sur twitter pour pouvoir
me donner des ordres pour la prochaine
vidéo du genre jeu aussi de créer un
compte
snap shot voilà c'est squeeze lucas il
me semble oui ça doit être ça du coup je
pourrais vous en voyez par exemple une
photo de ma superbe zone interdite de
poils @ exquisite suzuka voilà vous êtes
au point vous êtes top vous le savez je
suis sûr vous saviez et on se retrouve
très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo comme
d'habitude portez vous bien tu as tout
le monde pis
mike
[Applaudissements]